[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
Ця вулиця дуже схожа на старовинні вуличики Євпаторії,
[Харків,
Слобожанщина]
Феодосії, Сімферополя та інших кримських міст.
І саме тут, у цьому районі, у 40-их роках ХІХ століття
осіли харківські караїми.
[Олександр Дзюба
Голова Харківської караїмської громади]
Коли вони вперше приїхали з Криму в це місто,
то почали тут будувати й винаймати житло.
І одна з перших речей, яку роблять караїми,
коли приїздять в будь-яке місце
та засновують там своє поселення, —
це будують молитовний будинок.
Молитовний будинок у караїмів називається
кенаса (наголос на останню літеру).
Поруч на цих вулицях жили люди різних віросповідань:
караїми, юдеї, православні, католики, лютерани.
І, власне, ніхто ні з ким не конфліктував.
Харків — це місто, де не було єврейських погромів.
Люди жили спільно, люди жили мирно,
Харків завжди був містом миру, злагоди та діалогу культур.
[російською] Я перший раз сюди прийшов ще в 1998 році.
[російською] Коли тут навіть цю будівлю не повернули караїмам.
[російською] Тут було транспортне підприємство.
[російською] Мій приятель був другом
заступника директора цього підприємства.
[Олександр Махлаєв
Староста караїмської кенаси у Харкові]
[російською] На другому поверсі. Я сюди приходив просто в гості.
[російською] Я приходив, і мене завжди вражала будівля,
я завжди захюплювався ним.
[російською] Думав: «Яка гарна старовинна будівля»,
навіть не уявляючи, що тут було.
[російською] У 2007 році з появою Skype я зв'язався з братом,
[російською] і він мені розповів, що мій дід — паша
[титул в Османській імперії].
[російською] З 2012 року я став старостою караїмської кенаси.
Це Караїмська вулиця, колишня Караїмська.
Вона і є Караїмська зараз.
[Семен Морткович
Галицький караїм]
Тут жили караїми. І ось тут теж караїмський будинок.
Ось тут на честь караїмської кенаси
навіть поставили шпиль.
В суботу була відправа в кенасі.
І всі караїми з'їжджалися.
В цьому будинку жив один хазан [людина,
яка здійснює молитву в синагозі від імені присутніх].
Він учив караїмську молитву і жив в цьому будинку.
— Добрий день.
У 2002 році було вирішено створити музей.
Щоб музей став центром культури галицьких караїмів.
[Ніна Васильчук
Співробітниця Музею караїмської історії та культури]
Просто було видно, що нація, грубо кажучи, вимирає.
За однією з версій, у 1243 році
князь Данило домовився з ханом Батиєм
про дозвіл на міграцію караїмів з Криму для розвитку торгівлі.
У 1246 році до Галичі прибули
80 караїмських  родин: Солхато, Мавупо і Кафе.
Для розвитку торгівлі між Сходом і Даниловим князівством.
Караїмська мова належить
до кипчацько-уйгурської групи тюркських мов.
Караїм, наскільки ми бачимо, мусив знати мову Тори,
караїмську побутову мову
і ще мову того народу, де він проживає.
2005 року ми з дружиною побували у місті Євпаторія.
Відвідали там комплекс караїмських кенас.
На той час це була єдина діюча кенаса в Україні.
Там ми познайомилися з культурою, релігією,
історією кримських караїмів.
Мене зацікавило в караїмах те,
що головний принцип караїмської віри —
уважно читайте Тору і не спирайтесь на чужу думку.
Мене це надзвичайно вразило, і я почав вивчати
караїмську традицію релігійну.
Мій прапрадід був православним священиком,
і я не вважаю,  що я сповідую якусь іншу релігію,
що ми з ним належимо до різних релігій.
Ми просто по-різному трактуємо той самий текст.
В Україні найбільше скупчення караїмів — це кілька міст у Криму:
це Євпаторія, Сімферополь, там кількасот караїмів,
близько сотні у Феодосії живе.
За межами Криму, мабуть,
найбільше караїмів у Мелітополі  живе.
Трохи є в Києві, до речі, але там буквально кілька родин,
і там не може йтися про велику чи помітну громаду.
Але караїми там також живуть.
Окремі представники залишились в Галичі та Луцьку,
це лише окремі представники караїмського народу.
На жаль, в інших містах України, в місцях традиційного
розселення караїмів майже не залишилося.
Це називається «мацеви» [єврейський надгробок] — ось такі плити.
Ті всі караїми, котрі жили тут,
то вони всі поховані тут. Всі.
Оце мої всі родичі.
Чи єврей, чи караїм, чи руський, чи як вже після війни були руські,
то говорили: «Ти, москалю».
Так само і говорили: «Ти єврей» чи «Ти караїм» і тому подібне.
Ось навіть зараз, караїмською у мене ім'я — Шимон.
А як хто злий на мене, то кажуть:
«Ти, Шимку!» — ніби удар такий,
а я кажу: «Та й що, що я Шимко?»
Коли я робив, то писав Семен, а так я Шимон.
— А де чай був?
— А нащо тобі чай?
— Бо то не чай.
— Чай заварений вже.
Чай заварений стоїть на столі.
Свята такі у нас, підходять до іудейських,
у нас також мацу печуть:
на воді, на молоці, на сметані.
Традиції у нас подібні до єврейських, або юдейських.
Тому що в юдеїв маца не така, вона пресована.
Там мука й молоко не входять, а у нас інакше.
[російською] Намагаємось вчити забуту караїмську мову,
[російською] намагаємось підтримувати зв'язок з усіма нашими караїмами.
[російською] Деякі свята святкуємо разом.
[російською] Відкрили пункт прийому для переселенців,
допомагали речами та продуктами.
[російською] Серед караїмів теж є ті,
хто [залишив свої домівки] в Криму.
[російською] Наприклад, духовне правління Криму
зняли з посад взагалі, тобто тепер взагалі не існує.
[російською] Там знову ж таки йде боротьба.
[російською] Ну а нам, щоби зберегти ідентичність,
треба, щоб просто не заважали.
Караїми вважаються одним з малих корінних народів України.
Якщо ми беремо не в релігійному, а в етнічному розрізі,
то у караїмів немає іншої батьківщини,
окрім України, окрім Криму.
Варто сказати, що караїмізм як релігія розповсюджений
в дуже багатьох країнах Передньої Азії, Європи.
Але в жодній з цих країн караїми
не створили окремого етносу, окрім Криму.
Сімдесят років більшовицької влади завдали
величезних втрат караїмській спільноті.
Були знищені храми — кенаси.
Були знищені підручники, школи, вчителі.
Багато хто з носіїв знань були знищені.
Традиція перервалася.
Ці крихти колишньої величі,
колишнього життя ми намагаємося зберігати,
намагаємося нести й передавати наступним поколінням.
І, власне, згадувати те, що було втрачено.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Назар Салабан]
Макс Завалля, Сергій Розов]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастасія Климова]
[Субтитрувальник
Андрій Довгань]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США
з міжнародного розвитку USAID]